taryn when did you come to Los Angeles I
first came to last night well my first
came to Los Angeles when I was 19 for a
summer between freshman and sophomore
year in college and it's sort of like a
trial trip and I was here you know for
the summer and went back I think day
before school started because I did not
want to come home and that was the first
time and then I came out here for real
in the fall of two thousand one and have
stayed ever since and yeah there was
this I remember a plane ride I don't
remember when it was I guess it was when
I was coming back in two thousand one I
just looked out the window when I was
landing in LA and it I didn't even think
about it i just looked out the window
and I was like home like I just like it
just thought popped through my head and
I was like
it's not my home at all ya know
Chicago's my home but but it was I don't
know this is an interesting thing to
sort of notice that I felt very
comfortable here having spent only three
months here and my life ever so yeah
well aside from the weather obviously
yeah vs chicago what did you notice
about the energy here in LA the people i
noticed the space here
because I don't know if you've been to
New York but i I've only been to New
York for three days in my entire life
and the energy there is palpable and
there's this I don't know if it was in
my mind or if it was on the streets or
whatever but there was this feeling of
everyone's achieving things everyone's
going quickly and and here I don't have
that sort of pressing sensibility of
other people even though i'm sure people
are achieving things but there's this
this wonderful space that you don't have
in New York it's I don't know there's
something about my personality or
something that I just feel like I need a
lot of room I don't know why that is but
um but I feel like that's why I came to
LA in some way as opposed to New York
because here I have you know you have a
bigger apartment when you first move
here then you would you there's just
room there are the little pockets of la
ville little suburbs or whatever you
want to call them and I just like that I
think long term I kind of just need that
room I don't know why but it's it feels
right it feels right to be here and
space as opposed to being in a concrete
jungle to some extent
you